this episode is brought to you by Good
Omens a new series premiering May 31st
on Amazon Prime video this summer we're
getting honest about summer blockbusters
past and present this is honest trailers
Blockbuster summer before you catch men
in black international and six months on
cable are on an airplane or something
check out the film that started it all
and the other two that just kept doing
it the men in Black's sudha for three
sci-fi comedies set in an alternate
reality where the United States accepts
refugees and join the men in black
Galaxy defenders they're agents who
operate with no accountability when
branching of government reports are for
none I asked him any questions delete
people's memories keep everyone under
surveillance operate secret prisons and
beat the aliens they police within an
inch of their lives so it's a screwball
comedy about the deep state only in the
90s computer internet welcome to New
York land of a-holes please but some of
these a-holes are aliens who get to live
undercover as major celebrities every
one of those cranes is an alien you're
breaking up as Nick stereotypes Mikey or
yeah it's really just one of those two
they'll have to deal with agents J and K
played by an increasingly lumpy Tommy
Lee Jones and Will Smith at the height
plateau and depth of his powers
okay well for the scene
think about how you just start in seven
pounds lol at J and K in the first film
where K shows J the ropes while being
hunted by a villain who can kill people
instantly unless you're the heroes as
they search for an all-powerful device
that was right under their nose all
along the second one where J shows K the
ropes while being hunted by a villain
who can kill people instantly unless
you're the heroes as they search for an
all-powerful device that was right under
their nose all along what and the light
and the third wood where J goes back in
time to show K the Rogues while being
hunted by a villain who can kill people
instantly unless you're the heroes as
they search for an all-powerful device
that was yada yada yada are we sure we
want more sequels to this thing I don't
ask questions I don't want to know the
answer to but it's not just familiar
plots get ready for three films with the
same three jokes like the one where
aliens be horny keep an eye on her for
me they keep on in the man hey the one
where big things seem small and small
things seem big just because something's
important doesn't mean it's not very
very small
and the one that will make you ask how
many ribs could a Will Smith rib since a
wheel Smith RIS real good well yeah you
know could because he never appreciated
you anywhere how would I feel somebody
come running in okay question answered
so flashback to an era when summer
movies were more than just film they
dominated all pop culture with their own
toys tie-in sunglasses video games
cartoon series and of course smash hit
rap singles from the star over the
credits followed by a moderate hit rap
single for the sequel followed by a
generic pitbull song huh diminishing
returns like that kind of sums up the
whole franchise story
will the Minotti confirmed no country
for old spacemen snakes in a dame fin
O's jackass - what hu in the shadows
zeds dead baby zeds dead bug live Papa
Roach and GU looks like you got some
entrails on you there pal
guardians of the galaxy look out oh man
he killed your dad if only he had some
gonna time machine in your pocket you
have a time machine in your pocket this
episode was brought to you by Good Omens
a new series premiering May 31st on
Amazon Prime video my god
Zilla you could not live with your own
failure and where did it bring you back
to me long live the king pika pika